hello everyone Boris Goku is a pretty
amazing figure in the chess world he's
the only person to ever win the United
States Championship
and the Soviet championship as well and
he has a positive score against Garry
Kasparov out of the seven get a
classical games they played Luka won
three games three games were drawn and
only one game was won by Kasparov and
this is the third game they're playing
first game was drawn second was won by
Google so because part of probably wants
to win this game the game was played in
1982 so three years before
Kasparov became world champion and it
seems Kasparov's desire to win got the
better of him and well everybody was
always saying that Goku is the man and
go quiz the one to look out for but
allegedly he ran into some trouble with
the Soviets and the KGB and well he
wasn't allowed to play chess anywhere
outside of the Soviet Union so let's see
this game cuz part of has the white
pieces and he goes for d4 we have d5c
for the Queen's Gambit he captures on c5
c4 goko accepts the gambit and III
Knight to f6 Bishop captures on c4 e6
Knight to f3 and the c5 by goko cuz
power of castles we have a 6 e for b5
kicking that Bishop away Bishop to d3
and Bishop to b7 Bishop to g5 by
Kasparov C capture son d4 Knight capture
son d4 and Knight B to d7 of course go
can't capture this night because he
loses the Queen after Bishop captures
mb5 with check so after night the d4
Goku goes for Knight B to d7 Knight to
c3 developing and Knight to e5 by Goku
and this is the well the critical moment
in the game for Kasparov as well he
Kasparov in this position probably
should have went for something like
Bishop d2 not allowing Goku to target
this Bishop on d3 but Kasparov played
Knight C captures on b5 and what's the
idea why did
part of sacrifice a piece here well
because part of saw that if Coco accepts
the sacrifice a capture some b5 he had
bishop capture some beef I would check
night e to the seven blocking and then e
five and it seems that Kasparov is
getting the piece back because it's
impossible to keep the peace with h6 for
example Bishop to h4 g5 and now he
captures on f6 and if Coco would
recapture the piece with G captures on
h4 then Kasparov has this wonderful
resource of flying knife captures on e6
and this is a game over you can't really
capture the night because Queen to h5 is
instant checkmate and if you don't want
to capture it you have to play something
like King Queen to c8 as you do have to
defend this night on d7 because part was
threatening to capture it but after
Knight to g7 would check and King to b8
this rope to see one move ends the game
immediately as well the Queen has
nowhere to go
she has to defend this Knight and e7 and
as part of wins the Queen so of course
was part of really I guess wanted to win
this game and played a knife capture
some b5 but GU ko has an in-between move
he plays a knight captures on d3 and
what do you play here a well of course
Queen captures on d3 and now gogo
accepts the sacrifice a captures on b5
and well unfortunately capturing this
pawn now Queen doesn't really achieve
much as Queen capture some beef I would
check is met with Queen to d7 and the
Kasparov is well pretty much forced to
trade Queens he can go back but it
doesn't achieve that much but this might
have been his best chance for example
queen capture Sundy 17 captors 97 and f3
and he is down a piece but he has a past
a pawn in the past be pawn and this
might give him some drawing chances or
who knows how cool would play this maybe
even winning chances but after this a
capture some b5 Kasparov decided to go
to go all the way
and he played a rook F to d1 continuing
with the attack Bishop d7 by Goku and
the now Queen character son b5 Queen to
d7 because part of course doesn't wanna
trade Queens
Queen to b3 and mukou isn't afraid of
the soon to be world champion he
captures a pawn Bishop captures on e4
Knight to f5 is played and Goku goes for
Bishop to d5 and well of course the
knife can be captured as there is now a
discovered attack from the rook to the
Queen here so Bishop to d5 attacking
Kasparov's Queen and also defending his
own queen Knight to g7 captures on g7
with check King to f8 and here cuz power
plays Queen to h3 desperately trying to
make something happen
and bucco doesn't grab the night he
plays h5 although even even grabbing the
night is still better for black for
example Queen kept between to h6 check
King to g8 and our Bishop captures on f6
Bishop captures on f6 and Queen captures
on f6 and with a move like rook to a for
go code would be perfectly fine in this
position but he doesn't want to allow
Kasparov any activity so after Queen to
h3 he played h5
Kasparov goes for Queen to g3 and now
goku captures the knight King captures
on g7 we have Bishop captures on f6 not
with check and King captures on f6 Goku
is not afraid
rook to d4 and well here cuz Park has
some ideas if go is really gonna blunder
so maybe maybe for example its Queen to
d6 is played or if cocoa would offer to
exchange Queens like this then Casper
would have this rook turf or maybe but
who can even give up the Queen with
Queen captures on f4 and he's still
better only if he played a move like
Queen King 3 5 then Queen 33 would
result in checkmate after Bishop e4 and
Queen captures on e4
but of course after up to d4 Goku isn't
interested in any of this he plays the
simple bishop to this
making an escape route for his king Gani
seven and after Bishop to d6 jerricans
power resigned at the game and it turns
out to be a pretty pretty nice miniature
sorry Quintus III was played that he
didn't resign the game after Bishop to
d6 a queen to c3 was played King to g6
h3 and now after Bishop to c7 now cuz
Parra resigned the game but he might as
well resigned after that first Bishop to
d6 move because well Kasparov is down to
pieces and he doesn't really have a way
to continue this attack so yeah a very
nice game by boris kukoba man with the
positive score against Garry Kasparov
and the only man to ever win the United
States Championship and the Soviet
Championships yeah I would like to thank
Donna pirates for your contribution to
my channel and dogged McNabb thank you
as well I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon